hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about some weapons
practice so I feel for the patreon page
I haven't put up weapon stuff in a while
we're in the middle of summer here uh at
the dojo and that is when we do weapons
so we're doing weapons all the time so
it's just kind of on my mind so you guys
are going to get some weapon content for
a little bit here today we're going to
talk about the first uh Kum Joe as I
teach the first Kum Joe and the first
Kum Joe if if you're if you're following
along and you do iwama then you're going
to say that's the eighth Kum Joe
um and that it's very different than
cyto Sensei did it um and in the
inspiration of all of my Kum Joe come
from cyto sense I think they're really
very good um I just kind of don't like
the way they're organized and I think
there's a lot of talking points that
aren't really hit and there's a lot of
interesting stuff to talk about so um I
teach them in a different order and talk
about them in a different way so very
similar to scy the sensei's eth Kum Joe
but also pretty different um so I'm
going to call Josh be reew work
Josh
all right so let's talk about the first
form as I teach it um and that's the
eighth form from
cyos Kum Joe or very similar to that
eighth form um I teach this the first
form because I think it covers a lot of
good stuff right away so in this form uh
Josh and I are both going to be in ski
Kamai so we're going to be this position
and we're going to be out of range for
ski Kamai meaning right now if I came in
at Josh with a normal thrust actually
let's go this way if I came in with Josh
at a nor with a normal thrust uh I'm I I
don't I can't get him right so you know
and and that's not to say I couldn't hop
in and do an extra effort to get him but
we're looking at effort for effort right
so when you're when you're trying to
figure out any of this stuff you need to
think what is my Baseline and what is
their Baseline now can you do over your
Baseline yes but they can also do over
their Baseline so when you're trying to
like figure out you know like well I
could do this it's like well they could
do something also so what's the Baseline
for this the Baseline for this is in one
step I can't get Josh right okay so
we're both on each other in this all
right now when I want to get Josh of
course I could just take a step in that
preps my action right so I could just
come in here and now I'm in but I gave
him a lot of notification about what's
going on I gave him a lot of time to
adapt to whatever I'm going to do I did
an action that really doesn't do
anything besides set my distance right
doesn't give him anything he has to
worry about which means he can start
calculating what to do for me that gives
him an advantage I don't want to have
right I don't want him to have so what
I'm going to do in this is I'm actually
going to make my distancing an attack so
I can do that by using Jordan guch and
come in here and pop him now because of
the advantage of the Kamai of kin Kamai
versus the disadvantage in jooki then I
have this reach Advantage right so
meaning when we go like this if I'm
popping Josh and he comes to thrust me
he can't get me right even when he leans
in like that right so he still can't
quite get me so what you're looking for
is a way that I can make an advantage
once I'm in position so not just am I
getting to the distance I I need to get
into and not I'm just hitting him which
is great because that makes him react to
me but also I've accounted for my
secondary position which is really
really good so it's a great idea to
attack someone right and if this guy's
not very good I'm probably just going to
pop him he's not going to have a
response to that and it's going to be
really excellent for me okay now if he's
aware of this he can take advantage of
the fact that I have to still move
through this distance to get him right
so there is still a time where I'm
moving and I'm not striking exactly
during that time because I can't do the
simplest most efficient strike at this
distance so what he's going to do is
he's going to come in and hit me boom
okay so he's taking advantage of the
fact that my actions compound right so I
got to go up turn it over and hit him
jodan guch and he can just step in and I
am still stepping in so he's going to
meet me halfway so when I come in boom
he gets me there okay now the problem
for him here is he's got no protection
for his head so if I come down bang I'll
I'll hit him so he'll hit me cool but he
hasn't accounted for a second position
in this so that's not exactly a great
move right however because of hand in
hand speed if he brings his hands up as
I bring my hands down he'll still be
able to defend himself right so across
the board when I teach all my weapons
form stuff this number one idea is how
to deal with a low attack and manage a
high attack at the same time so this
bits also my number one with the sword
my number one with everything else so as
I come in up high he hits me bang like
this okay now hand forand action as I
come down he can protect his head so
we've got a nice counter for him he can
attack me and defend himself however if
he can steal a little time meaning he's
a little faster he can do even more with
this so meaning as he hits me he's going
to immediately start stepping off line
in my last little bit of a step and he's
going to then hit me again bang so he's
hit me twice now now my reaction would
be to come to his legs so what he's
going to do is slide that stick in
between my hands and now I can't get to
his legs with any kind of power right
well what's my idea my idea is I have to
clear this weapon somehow how am I going
to do that I'm going to pull it free
like this okay now if as I go to pull it
free he sticks right with me he's going
to bind my arms up and toss me away and
so we get the full form in this right
okay so initially our big first idea is
how do I cover that distance in a clever
way it's a clever way he just happens to
be a little better than me right so as I
come in he pops me down low he defends
himself gets off the line and I miss him
he catches my hand so I can't come in
here and follow up on the attack as I
raise up he sticks right with me and
brings me over now there's a ton of
other little things that could happen in
this but those are all already accounted
for in the way this is built and the
ones that don't account for it will be
accounted for in the second form so
there's 10 of these these forms they all
just answer questions that the other
ones pose but let's look at one big
obvious one right so as I come in he
hits me bang I come down he gets offline
he's protect his head and that whole
nine yards all right now when I go to
hit him here let's say I'm a little
faster if I'm a little faster and I go
to hit him he's already in banino Kamai
so he's already defended and because
it's banin noai he can defend all the
way to his leg so if I came down to his
knee he's still defended his knee so
while he's getting off line he's still
in a defended position so if I'm faster
it doesn't matter it doesn't turn out as
well for him because I'm quicker but
he's still protected the whole time okay
now once he catches in here and he
Tangles up my arms could I just let go
with this hand because the problem is
this hand can't go in towards him
because he's locked this hand in place
so I can't can't get into him right
could I just let go and hit him here
sure but the hit would be like this
right so I I could probably line up and
let Josh hit me like this all day with
the stick and it would only get annoying
after about the 15th hit you know what I
mean so so this is not a tremendously
powerful hit and if I let go here he can
washy right there into my face right so
if I take my hand out of place I'm going
to get a crummy shot and he's going to
break my nose right so really a good
trade for him if that's the trade we had
to make okay now what if I want to get
my hands out and I want to do it in the
way that he can't follow me up right so
I could just pull my hands this way when
I do that I expose the entirety of my
back to his waiting weapon right so he
has the backside and the front side both
that are right there so as I come back
in he's completely defended so this is a
really good position for him to set
himself up in and answers a lot of the
problems I'm going to give him so this
is a nice first form to start looking at
you can look at the difference and
advantages between different kinds of
Kamai and you can look at the
differences in distances and timings and
what happens how to defend a position
like your secondary position so as I go
in how do I defend my secondary position
so a lot of good stuff in this form I
teach this the first form and I kind of
build all the other forms off of this
hope that was helpful for you guys I'm
Chris fres Joshua thi my salon McDaniels
behind that camera right there we'll see
you in a future video